[Music]
you found yourself at the junction where
worlds meet politics civility how about
honesty in this country folks
entertainment I don't know whole bunch
of other stuff
about having a healthy body image you've
a very unhealthy body you should have a
horrible body it's not a big coming
through market maturity we are
definitely going to get letters you're
listening to talk radio strangest animal
[Music]
you're getting louder with Crowder
[Music]
that that means it's the sound of the
weekend glad to be with you i am your
host steven crowder with me producing as
always in a video studio video stream is
not gay jared he is not gay follow him
at not gay Jared on Twitter I fulfilled
my legal obligations draw your own
conclusions we good we're good I'm even
more glad to be with you this is true
what would be the more get into that a
couple we have to let people know our
guests yes we have legendary comedian
Nick DiPaolo on tonight so if you don't
follow him you need to follow him if you
don't know who he is learn who he is and
of course we have based mom christina
hoff sommers dr. christina hoff sommers
by popular demand she was there with me
at umass and we weren't able to get her
on that week we were already booked so
he brought her on this week and i'm
excited to to get in the fold with those
two well let's let people know about not
gay Jared he was sick I don't want you
can reveal what you want to reveal he
was in the emergency room this week can
we talk about the blood transfer yeah
all right let's hit hit him with that
real quick we'll go back to it cuz we
have to get to the Trump stuff this week
yeah lost lost a lot of blood apparently
that's not good it's not good not good
they don't advise it so blood
transfusion first time at that five
units of blood
that's your first time that I know of I
mean I've had surgery before because we
talked about that but you know I don't
know if I had transfusion mid surgery or
not I'm not aware but she was on the
other foot because you don't you don't
want to none of that gay blood well you
told me about that and they told me
worst case scenario was aids but the
best case was superpowers so I took the
razor the gamble it's a roll of the dice
you just you also don't know what
superpower well the bummer part is I
know I don't have superpowers yet we're
still waiting on the we're still waiting
still waiting well your hemoglobin level
was really six point two to 12 right
yeah at least 12 something like that
twelve sixteen twelve sixteen so the
optimal range is probably closer to six
yeah not not cultured to death you just
took away the one before the sixteen and
and that was where you were so what
we'll talk about that more after the
break was a scary week for not gay Jared
and we're mostly glad that he's back a
lot of stories this week so obviously
listen the big one is and we
why are you talking about politics so
much we get so tired of it every now and
then and on isn't tired of it honestly
when you know Tuesday happened I wasn't
even following it I don't care that much
anymore people going are like I was past
it at this point you know obviously I'm
not the biggest Trump fan but he won and
here's one thing I will say you know I
said on Twitter I said hey you know
congratulations Trump on the win and Ted
Cruz classy move dropping out trying to
unify the party that's all I said and
people went nuclear you're on the Trump
bandwagon you idiot have you ever been
in a sport have you ever competed have
you ever been in a debate in a high
school college debate club I've lost to
people who I can't stand and I have to
well you know what those are the rules
shake their hand congratulate them on
the win but it seems and if Hillary
Clinton wins I do not like Hillary
Clinton I would not be happy but I've
got to say okay all right you you won
congratulations on the win were you
raised that way congratulations on the
win I hope you die yeah you can wish for
it is entirely appropriate take your
little doll and you stick the pins in it
yeah but you know like I buy your back
in t-ball you always did that no matter
who won who lost he always did the
little lineup and tap bands on the way
and the problem is Jared was talking
about t-ball last week and a good time
but that's the problem though with
social media with elections and white
gets exhausting you have people who've
never entered the arena I've never been
in a fight never been in any kind of a
struggle and then they think that their
opinions are as informed or mean as much
as everyone else and here's the truth
everyone can have an opinion your
opinion isn't necessarily as valid as
someone else's and it isn't as of much
value as other people and it also
depends on the person whom you're
expressing the opinion to me right
someone like John Stossel
his opinion means a lot more to me than
not gay Jared that's okay they can both
have opinions doesn't mean I trust them
so Trump won that's the reality he what
my opinion matters at least somewhat
then doesn't prove them from last but
it's because of the sympathy right now
well I'll take it I don't want you
looking like like Tom Hanks from
Philadelphia everyone sees you bald and
there's a make-a-wish Foundation and all
they remember is that
mean man who told your start a
foundation this is not you could always
start a foundation it's not a
conservative
so does this change what I think about
Trump no will I vote for Donald Trump
I've always said this no probably not
now I reserve the right to change if
I've always said this if Donald Trump
starts surrounding himself with
brilliant people brilliant people not
Sarah Palin not Roger stone
okay people who are really brilliant who
are constitutionalist who understand how
to run a government and surround himself
with those people who I think are
trustworthy I reserve the right to
change my opinion I referred to change
my opinion period but does this change
how I feel about Donald Trump it doesn't
but I feel the need to to congratulate
someone on the win people say well why
don't you get on board with the never
Trump I've never been on board with that
even though long before never Trump I
said on the show it's Donald Trump I
probably won't vote for him why because
the problem with the hashtag never Trump
is what I saw was it wasn't about I will
never vote for Donald Trump
it was never Trump even at the cost of
collusion and even though people have
lobbed it at me that will you want that
you want the election to be stolen I
don't want the election to be stolen I
was pretty clear the reason there's a
very specific number one two three seven
delegates that didn't just it wasn't
pulled out of a hat and I said if Donald
Trump gets those delegates he wins
period and if the GOP pulls something
pulls out Paul mr. p90x Ryan I will
relieve myself in the GOP Asha's which
is that picture of Hamelin doing the
curls the p90x kid like yeah like they
took the pictures so you can see the
hair on the back of his knees there is
no more unattractive place for hair we
all have it but you don't show it I
don't I don't have it I think I know for
a fact that's your superpower the
ability to grow me hair ah it's growing
on the interior of your kneecap so I
always said that about about Paul Ryan
but if he doesn't and it goes to a
contested convention that's not new it's
happened and we'll see what happens in
the ballot Donald Trump gets those
delegates he wins Donald Trump one other
people pulled out okay that's reality
that's where we are you don't
necessarily like it I don't necessarily
like it
Yuri Onassis for Ted Cruz and Carly
Fiorina people think you know because
we've had them both in the show I liked
Carly Fiorina
they think we haven't been critical
enough of them well listen I don't
pretend to be an unbiased journalist
right I'm an entertainer how do you
stand up on this show as a mix of comedy
and in politics and entertainment but we
have been pretty brutal on them if you
actually listen to the sketches between
the segments but we've done some freedom
in the Carly Fiorina Barren womb bit in
the GOP debate cartoon like we have
criticized everybody now naturally with
my opinion I'm going to favor Carly
Fiorina or Ted Cruz over at Donald Trump
that's okay because I like their
policies more than Donald Trump but
we've had plenty of criticism and here's
some more of it Ted Cruz and Carly
Fiorina deserve to lose I like them I
wish they didn't they deserve to lose
now they were fighting against a reality
show big-name or talk about name
recognition in the American public right
now right you have Hillary Clinton big
name recognition Donald Trump big name
recognition they were fighting it and
they thought they were gonna play it
safe and go the traditional route they
deserved to lose they thought they were
going to go in the traditional AM radio
circuit Fox News and they were going to
win with the Republican base it's not
enough it's not enough they were running
their campaign like champions and by the
way this is necessarily because of them
but because of advisers and strategists
we get I've taken you off we get these
emails all the time from people who want
us to have politicians on you know
senators or congressmen we're only
interested in national politicians
because otherwise it just gets so boring
they're the most boring guests you could
possibly have know do we want the
senator from X district in Oklahoma now
we better have nicked Apollo on so these
people are advising them telling well
let's go let's go the safe route let's
go let's play traditional media let's
focus on white Christian conservatives
am I saying they're racists no but that
was their absolute game plan which isn't
enough when we had took Carly Fiorina
Ted Cruz in this program for the first
time
now listen do we do massive numbers no
but the programs with Carly Fiorina and
Ted Cruz bigger than CNN well well under
the six figures combined seven figures
on the downloads the the videos and the
clips and we've got tons of comments
from people saying I never I never seen
them like this I never heard Ted Cruz
talk about pink floyd--
or Carly Fiorina they came on good time
we invited them back and I know for a
fact that they were scared you place
about the [ __ ] after a presidential
candidate mmm they're like well you know
we're kind of attacking Donald Trump
over the Howard Stern thing which is
stupid they don't want to come back I
understand that so let's remove us from
the equation they're just so they're
just so out of touch when we're talking
about young people by the way anyone
under the age of 40 Republicans
anyone under the age of 45 and you lose
that's the issue here and they show you
know Ted had his whole teens for Ted
thing where was it it was it was at CJ
Pearson kid oh yeah enough to vote you
probably hadn't had his balls drop yet
knew Murray was calling it can I get on
your show can I be like no you can't get
on her show now he's a surrogate for
Bernie purchase any swindled
conservatives out of thousands of
dollars for a speaking tour and Ted
Cruz's this is you know if if if 25 is
young if 30 is young and relevant 14 is
really relevant we want a Shaun King for
our team they were so risk-averse and
here's the thing you have to go big or
go home in this campaign I am NOT a
campaign strategist but if I could run
it you need to be running at guerrilla
warfare Kim let's remove us from the
equation
Adam Carolla Joe Rogan popularly YouTube
channels Carly Fiorina Ted Cruz did none
of that none of it okay Ted Cruz you
wanted Fox and Friends every couple of
weeks what else you got and that's what
listen that's where a lot of people like
Milo the alt-right I don't agree with
them on a lot of principle but the
reason we can discuss is because I don't
just go - never Trump okay let's discuss
these ideas there right there's not a
lot of originality in the conservative
movement right now no we're very
fortunate we benefit from that and
that's why you have people appearing on
on cable news lifting bits from kids in
a dense studio as we saw this week with
the Kasich and closing time and the
people at Ed are oh we don't care but
they're taking cues from people who are
on mediums they should have been paying
attention to all along yep
conservatives think this is new media
still like be literally thing they said
no it's not new it's been around for a
long time you're just too silly to have
noticed it we'll talk more about this
after the break I'm gonna have an
aneurysm
[Music]
[Applause]
Awful's bragging mill the louder wolf
crawler I'm Perry Madison we tell you
now on with our on the field reporter
Jimmy in Flint Michigan where the
President Barack Obama himself has flown
on Air Force One to pay the struggling
residents of a city once famous for a
swarming crime rate now a most notorious
for its fungi ridden tap water of visit
Jimmy and Jimmy's dad will keep you
abreast as the story unfolds a louder
with crawler I'm very mall hey Steven
what are you doing I'm just browsing
Eric 15.com
give me the site about the scared like
rifle with the best prices community and
information on the web now what the hell
is a difference hey 15.com yeah 15 15 a
calm you know they just heard the three
tapes you did three tapes you didn't
edit it they can hear you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right glad to be back uh I'm going
to wrap up the Donald Trump we have so
many great guests tonight that I can't
go on too many too many rants with this
yeah let me just say this
I like Senator Ted Cruz I like Carly
Fiorina they're welcome on the program
and even I am tired of their faces and
their voices yeah I don't like I'm not a
Donald Trump fan I hope that people on
the never Trump side still understand
riling up and I hope that the people who
love Donald Trump think that this is
entirely reasonable I don't have to like
somebody I can express my policy
disagreements my disagreements on ideas
and still be okay with the rules if
Bernie Sanders won I would soil myself
and I would say all right good game you
hundred and fifteen year old socialist
Jew who's never held a private job you
did it I don't I don't know how you did
it's not that I'm lazy it's that I just
don't care I think a lot of people have
hit that point yes I say Kim Davis thing
remember the Kim Davis image never
seemed to want to end ever right it's
just like you're like ah and there was a
lot of nuance there her face again yeah
there's some more of her face sort of
Hoarders back to her face and then her
face on hoarders dad I was weird episode
it was a weird episodes good though it
was good it was just a bunch of cutlery
like Kerry's mom where she is right you
never saw the original Kerry I did
actually you remember when all that all
the knives go into her and that was one
of those scenes where washing just
immensely uncomfortable stop what are
you doing care but of course that's when
Christians show up in the film or
Kerry's mom okay so people are Evan
asking and hopefully I'm along I'm going
to let you take a little bit of the lead
because I it to the audience you can
tweet me at us Crowder for questions
people actually care about you some
people and you got sick so I was ready
for the Monday morning meeting you
didn't come in and you were rushed to
the hospital hospital it's like a hotel
by the way it's nice it's a very nice
Hospital nice house but literally they
use the same furniture my wife works
with furniture as the Hyatt
like the Ottomans and stuff like that
yeah and your food wasn't bad either my
food actually you know I had a lot of
work done at Cleveland Clinic that's
where I'd like all my stuff done when I
lived there and I mean number you know
top hospital in the country you know in
the world but this place is actually a
better food than Cleveland Clinic the
rooms were comparable and you didn't
have to be in Cleveland so tell me tell
me what you had I know I've been keeping
it relatively close to the chest and
then when I went in you were telling
anyone who would listen just a little
bit of a Sade c-diff c-diff Sita fades
see the fades fades - the AIDS
once you have no colon our audience
knows that and watch some FCC block any
get scatological no he has no : he can't
take a crap this is medical do you
realize that I can call Hillary Clinton
a [ __ ] but I can't say that Jared needs
to take a dump they have to hit that
sound button
it's the tragedy it was so silly public
internet oh by the way speaking of radio
thank you so much 2k an easy one on
seven point three FM in Reno for picking
us up earlier thank you so much for
picking us up just as the nurse picked
up Jared's colostomy bag so tell them
what happened what you don't have
anymore okay for those can we say that
huh not without getting detail how you
lost blood but think that would probably
figure it out no : no : so you're not
I'm not I don't want to leave us no but
now we're pretty honest with the
audience yes so and I get a call and
like this isn't that abnormal for Jared
but I was concerned and you know we were
I didn't sleep at all Sunday night
because I was talking with with you know
your family members and they were kind
of updating me and so you're in the
hospital they give you a transfusion and
you have c-diff right c-diff yeah I had
an NG tube to be tested that's all they
tested at first that was a lot of fun
the what an NG tube you've read that
before
no they literally shove a straw through
your nose no no up your nose down your
throat and suck out the contents on your
stomach to see what's there oh I've had
that because I drank a whole bottle of
like asking me to Fenway with yes it's
the worst well yeah I had my stomach
pumped
yeah that was probably the worst thing
about the whole thing - they just like
had not been able to eat for like
I mean but could have been worse if not
for your I mean I will hand it to your
inhuman gag reflex
it comes with years of practice so you
have c-diff and here's the thing we do
this do we have a den built studio out
of my where I live and they're telling
me wipe down your hands any bacterial
soap and hand sanitize them to not get
seed if I'm going not gay Jarrod will
literally come into my house and just
coat the bowl with a second coating of
paint seven times a day and I'm worried
about washing my hands so I don't even
know is this something I need do I need
to go see a doctor you should probably
get tests I should probably get this how
do they tell have to do that thing if
that wouldn't be fun for me you should
tape it well sometimes have to do a
sample of a word we can't say and you
have to figure it that's what they
figured out the intestinal bacteria
stuff and by the way tweet not gay
Jarrod as a friend but also his employer
he needs to be healthier so no I don't
want to say this was preventable but
everyone here knows about his diet
habits and and the you got it you gotta
get on top of that you do I said as a
friend and also you know as obviously we
want you to get into work but it's not
good for you I've had lots of signals
lately those yeah there's a protein
right well I'm sure they're fortified
with vitamins okay so seed if that's the
case and something else I want to say so
not gay Jarrod one of his relatives is
there and I've talked we have a
registered sex offender on the block who
allegedly so we know he's registered sex
offender we know he's harassed many
people he spends all kinds of nights in
the drunk tank and he allegedly molested
a special-needs guy in our blog we've
talked about him I don't know if he
views his actual name and I don't know
you remember this but I was sitting and
I was complaining because especially
this this child molester has another
ally on the block now sitting there now
washing my hands I'm going for crying
out loud you know what does it take I
got a guy the guy raped a [ __ ] and
your relative would one you've never met
who have never met was there a
conversation after I left there was but
surprisingly involve nothing of raping
retards so you got off I remember he
just walked in I'm going
and I said hey that Ken without context
that could sound bad I'm literally
talking about somebody who sexually
molested a special-needs child he raped
a reason or mille well you got remember
I'm around you all the time so it's not
abnormal for me but when I think like oh
this person isn't see you at all ever
most of the tweets are very nice get
healthy people are know about your gag
reflex
Chewbacca's lover tweeting us I held it
close to my chest
Stephen clatter 2016 been there now I'm
all just a bunch of gay jokes to be
honest I really thought the audience
would've been more competitive this is
what happens oh well all right well we
have come back with crease
dr. christina hoff sommers yep and
that's going to be great so we'll hold
your questions until after that louder
with Crowder christina hoff sommers
coming up she's a doctor stay tuned
[Music]
and now for John Kasich only superfan at
a primary watch party hey guys thanks so
much for inviting me yeah yeah it's cool
man I'm glad I'm telling you you think
you only have two choices with Trump and
Cruz you really want to take a better
look at Kasich oh yeah really he's the
only one who beats Hillary Clinton in a
head-to-head in a national polling
telling me I mean oh yeah we have a lot
of name recognition no it's because John
Kasich is the only one who knows how to
deal with the political divisive nacinda
days atmosphere you know I don't know
man I just don't really think this is
because even on the research if you did
the redid the research on Kasich who
even you changed your mind official word
from the Ted Cruz campaign that he has
suspended his presidential campaign
until further wow-wow that's it if Ted
Cruz couldn't win Indiana he said he
should drop out I told you you should
drop out if he can't win Indiana Kasich
could have won that without Ted Cruz in
their case it's the only one left right
now it's between Trump or Kasich and I'm
telling you it's time to start taking a
serious look he can really fix that you
know he's still only one what one state
does it get Roe Gnaeus
okay erroneous at this point he's the
only one left he it's him and Trump you
have a choice to hurt getting it now
that John Kasich has also officially
suspended his presidential campaign
[Music]
okay we are now joined so keep your keep
your mouth in line they're not gay Jared
a classy lady and do it everyone knows
who this Westing or and I was fortunate
enough to share the stage where you can
watch your stuff on youtube youtube.com
slash factual feminist or follow her on
Twitter CH summers Somm ers christina
hoff sommers thank you for being with us
well I know I assure you have no
intention sometimes the the screaming
belligerent one can capture the most
amount of attention but well thank you
you did a fantastic job you know what we
talked about this you Milo and myself we
were talking about this you know I went
out and you knew before I was kind of
like you were gonna do your speech and
Milo was gonna do his bit and I was
going I had a stand-up list and setlist
and then I said but I don't know if
these kids are going to allow it and
then what triggered me so to speak was
you just I expected it with Milo and he
was so short you went out at UMass for
people who haven't watched the full
lecture we have it up at the website and
just how vile and vulgar and angry they
were with you it just sets something off
for I was going okay if if Christina
Hoff Sommers who's taught philosophy for
twenty years doesn't have a shot at some
kind of a civil conversation
alright that's out the window and that's
kind of that was my mindset so it was
you who inspired me because I wanted to
beat their faces in it was astonishing
and as you said I expected that Milo
would create some chaos students would
listen more or less right because I
don't say anything inflammatory I try to
reason with them and they all had
already passed out flyers quoting me
quite an oculus quotes by the way yes
it's simply questioning a wage gap myth
or questioning that you know swathmore
or Wesley and these are rape cultures
they say that you are a dangerous and
violent person well exactly and and no
sense of irony that they're saying that
well
literally don't have enough middle
fingers to give as we walk out on stage
well not gauge it was we talked about
that last week he's seen me do stand-up
he knew right away he's like this is not
what Stephen does expectations I sort of
thought of myself addressing students in
a lecture called performance art and you
refer to it as an act and I don't and
somehow it shouldn't have worked but it
was very effective in raising awareness
right what has happened on our campus
yes and I think you know I'm funnily
enough people going to I've never seen
crowd of this mad because if people
actually watch this show it's very it's
very much like you're experiencing right
now it's very conversational I mean
we've had people come on and call for my
death and I just go well that's
interesting I disagree with you but then
the stand-up is it is different and you
know is it was just it was like Michael
Douglas and falling down I'd had enough
and I think that surprised people
because I'm not a I am an angry person
but I'm not explosive in that way
publicly generally speaking but a lot of
people if you look at the reactions so
let's let's get enough about me darling
they were talking about you and in
people who weren't even you know we
talked about you it was 600,000 the full
lecture you know one point six seven
million on my rant overwhelmingly
positive for you just as much as I
mostly you people love you these aren't
conservatives the majority of these
people if you look at YouTube you just
crunch the numbers have to be Center or
left and and you've not really been a
Republican you like you said you're kind
of a lifelong registered Democrat but
yes we'll get to that too because that's
interesting interesting conversation
right now but that was a reaction with
you people going I can't believe she
seems have told me and I haven't
verified this that the crowd was
actually angriest when I was talking but
I infuriated them more and they were
noisier than no again I haven't checked
it out but every time I attempted to
speak there was so much fury and I was
trying to be generous to them trying to
understand that because I do think I
mean as a comedian you don't have to do
this but
I like to meet them halfway rules yes I
couldn't do it no no
well I and on this show I always do that
and we invited actually some of those
students on the show and they haven't
come on the show really yes I invited
the girl who wrote the letter yeah a
couple of them if I can find Wrigley
puff I'd invite her but I think I think
she's in her natural hibernation cycle
no no don't do that I felt that way too
no no she's not she's not [ __ ] and I
work with special needs people she's not
[Laughter]
no I think I think that the criticism
should focus on the professors who
enraged her because she's just she acted
out yes they want you to move on but
that's not cyberbullying she showed up
and was trying to take food from the
mouths of my family and your family
because a big part of our living is
speaking engagements and she's hungry so
that's where I lose the empathy this
wasn't she wasn't filmed in a restroom
and made fun of for her weight she
showed up to yell and swear and cuss you
out she saw that ride and she bought a
ticket and she rolled the dice she lost
this has happened on every campus where
I've been where they acted out at
Oberlin where they had their safe space
and 30 women and a dog therapy dogs led
to the same space and at Georgetown in
it both those universities the students
looked foolish and people had it took
photos and then the students were
horrified that people posted their
photos so not only are they childish in
the way they protest in the way they
think in their view of the world but
when they go out to protest they have a
temper tantrum if people call them out
on it right no it's it's a great point
and this is the first generation and
that's kind of what I think was
reflected and people went aha with my
rent this is the first generation of
people who are fighting for less rights
they're fighting for less freedoms
that's their fight absolutely I was in
college the idea of having Dean's
monitoring our personal lives out of the
question we didn't we didn't want to
call in the police and call in the
administration and our everyday baby we
wanted them out of our lives we want it
to be independent liberated beings and
today I call this fainting couch
feminism it takes us back to the
Victorian era right the hysteria the
demand for adults to supervise every
every thing they do do every little
thing that happens to them they run
screaming to their parents and Families
ation
and I think it goes beyond politics oh
absolutely
people are struggling to understand
what's happened on campus but I think it
may have to do with the helicopter
parenting or this self-esteem movement
something has gone badly wrong with a
certain sector of privileged Millennials
the more elite the kids are the more
prestigious the school inexpensive the
school the more likely this is to happen
that's a good point you don't see kids
probably going to trade school or kids
who aren't going to college who are
going into construction you don't see
them acting as professional protesters
even if they might be Union Democrats
right yes that's a good active as
privileged write that down not kids they
absolutely [ __ ] yeah someone's going to
lift that from you and claim it as their
own so we'll have this as as the record
here for that yeah you know trick'd
Wrigley puff is is interesting in the
sense it's I know I said that name we
don't have any other name for her but
I'm not no I think Trigg Lee puff works
works just fine she was so angry and so
upset and the reaction like we said with
with you was disarming in in that people
she one thing had to defend you because
there were some people I member saying
well it didn't sell it they were that
destructive to me and one person is
Christine christina hoff sommers clearly
just would repeat herself because she
couldn't no no no you don't understand
she
here herself we couldn't hear each
people understand you know the sound is
going out to people and the only
recording they're getting right is the
microphone like right now my dog is
snoring you can't hear them
that's why in comedy when they tape
especially have mics in the audience so
people only hear a reaction and in to be
fair you I would seem if they don't hear
this that you're stuttering but really
they're interrupting you so much you
have to restart your point and when I
wrote that down some people you know the
leftists very small minority saying well
I guess I don't see that and of course
when you turn the camera on the audience
then they did see that you know you
don't hear trigger puff in the original
video it produced my favorite meme
probably of the night though which was
the doctor summers the Socrates Socrates
my favorite become places where people
go to feel comfortable and safe rather
than to challenge you know to be
challenged and to learn new ideas new
thoughts then the universities will lose
their reason for being and since and
what I tried to say was since the time
of Socrates higher education has been
synonymous with debate with contention
with examining ideas with with could you
know being held responsible for the
clarity of your thought well if this
disappears then as I said what happens
to education it becomes a kindergarten
what's a good bless what people call her
based mom have you heard that nickname
based race mom base mom okay I correct
my low but I I do want to correct you at
a couple of things and there was there
was no way to do it in that environment
what I do think that you should might
want to consider modifying your position
on Islam because of course there are
tariffs and and and dangerous people and
then people that are you know have very
backward views sure but you must
acknowledge a growing number not big
enough but it's growing number of
liberal Muslims Irshad Manji and
Australia
Nnamani wonderful reformists they happen
to be religious but they want to bring a
kind of enlightenment to Islam I think
it was Australian OB she posted her
demands someone nailed it into the door
of a Washington is Islamic Center right
and these we have to support them and so
if you say things that suggest that you
you know have some animus towards all
those little I said the opposite I
understand where you're coming from but
I was very clear to single out Mohammed
and I will stand by that Mohammed was a
terrorist historical record is uneven
there are examples of things that he did
that were progressive you have to put it
in the time that he lived
yes I understand but Christian figures
there there's a lot of problematic base
not anywhere near that and I would say
because you know if you look at
historically Christianity and its
inception where they were known
oppressors and right Stephen the first
martyr right stoned to death
it was clear oh you're Christian you're
dead with Islam it then you know no one
knew in Mohammed was no one really cared
so even when there were no known
oppressors it was always spread through
the sword historically and my I
understand what you're saying I would I
would be appalled if someone said I hate
all Muslims but I do I do stand by my
statement in my world you that Mohammed
was the original Isis founder and there
are a lot of Muslims who part way with
that but to talk that way I think it's
accurate
I mean King David Jewish history a very
uneven record you could say all sorts of
things but it would be so hurtful to
Jewish people to hear it put them know
they know words that about King David
big mouth now the big difference is King
David first off King David is not the
the holiest of prophets and he's widely
regarded as a very flawed King who was
able to do great things Mohammed is
regarded as the most perfect human being
who ever lived
he's the prime example and I would say
that's two that's two very different
things just like Samson is not the
perfect being just like Moses is not but
Mohammed is and Mohammed is no
if people can't be certain the stories
about Muhammad it's it's all a matter of
interpretation there isn't it okay III I
have to go go to a break but let's bring
you back based mom factual feminist
I love it I love it we can have this
disagreement respectful stay tuned
glider with Crowder
[Music]
[Applause]
those bring you Perry Matheson on water
with Crowder issuing a correction
earlier in this evening's broadcast we
falsely stated that field reporter Jimmy
was deceased we've since learned that he
is still in Flint and capable of
communication Jimmy are you there Jimmy
Jimmy little Perry Matheson can you hear
me no it's prime Allison Jimmy can you
tell us what you see on the ground and
Flint what happened sounds terrible
Jimmy was staying with us can you fill
round through the debris can you make
sense of the event a sound and rest no
no Jimmy stay with me I know this is
hard if you could dig in deep here use
what you have my god Jordan ring in
German
[Music]
[Music]
right that's enough of that dancing we
had to cut the cut the factual feminist
off follow her follow her what are you
doing with your life at CH summers Somm
ers christina hoff sommers thanks so
much for being back so we left them at
this agreement no this does go out
terrestrial we occasionally we're gonna
let's make this three segments because
she's so good so i disagree with you on
that and also you know i can't travel to
huge portions of the world you know I'm
right next to Salman Rushdie on cares
watchlist and we've had very serious
security run-ins so it's it's it's not a
small minority of people I agree with
you that reformists should be recognized
but if we go back to David people aren't
aren't killing in record numbers and
haven't been doing so for David for
centuries and I always compare it if you
haven't seen the video I did a video
let's compare Jesus versus Muhammad
because I'm a horrible example for
Christians I know that I think comparing
the founder you know the founder of the
feast Jesus versus Mohammed yields two
very very different characters and and
two very different results in the in the
history of the religion but but I
understand where it's ok you y-you said
you had a couple Corrections it hit me
with the other ones because I but
believe me I'm not beyond it I'm willing
to accept that when you go to a campus
are you're facing you know very furious
activists who can't be reasoned with
your goal should be to convince the
people in the middle and you know you
can say things that will be pleasing to
your followers and your fans you want to
pitch it to the people in the middle who
are persuadable
and I think you'd I think your rant was
excellent even my somewhat liberal sons
thought you were great well so you you
you got past a lot of you know barriers
no I agree with you though I agree with
you um and I wrote okhla and I just
don't think you want to insult a whole
religion I mean there you just in and I
don't say they you always do but it just
sounded to me I wanted to clarify that
well yes it's important to delineate the
joke where I say you only I remember
what I said I made a joke the only way
he's gonna be beating on her if she is
if she puts on a job that's a joke and
then the Mohammed thing where I say
Muhammad is a terrorist oh come on
that's not fair this is the thing that
conservatives do its respectfully it's a
lot easier to take on feminists and
social justice whereas when it comes to
Islam you can hear the sphincters
puckering up yes hyperbole and and
actually they do the very thing they
accuse male patriarchy subdued because
you're a feminist nice and they
humiliate people they want to harm
people they've become the very thing
that they claim to dislike the people
they accused of being privileged and
want you know I want to describe all
these negative characteristics they have
taken on all those characteristics
otherwise to use their word and but we
won't continue with this right now we
can do it later but when it comes to a
religion it's very different because
people you're a Christian and you're
very sensitive about your religion it
says special places no I'm not I'm not
sensitive about it that's the thing I
think it's open to criticism and I have
a problem when one religion makes itself
immune to criticism and one religion
through a system of law wants to oppress
anyone for speaking out against it and
like I said when I formers would agree
as well they we should allow humor yes
criticism I mean we I'm not a Muslim but
the Muslims that I know that are trying
so hard to bring reform in the United
States though and that's well my point
right and my point too is when I said
I'm sure there are plenty people in this
room right but there is not an Islamic
country in existence not one where you
would be safe or my wife would feel safe
or people they people in the world there
are Muslim feminists who are struggling
for women's rights
there is no feminists in the West that
I'd aware of that ever reported that
kind of danger and
is something I lament is that in our
Women's Studies departments when they're
you know lamenting about I don't know
you know they're having they need a safe
space because someone broke Donald Trump
on charges on it and yet they should be
making common cause they should have
right you know some kind of bond with
these women in Iran you can be put in
this these horrible prisons for daring
to have a blog or playing rock music or
anything said I just so much wish the
the activists on our campuses would open
themselves up and and and look at the
world and what's going on in the world
and realize they are privileged they are
the benefit of the beneficiaries right
democracy of a humane society we're not
perfect but we are so much better than
so many parts of the world and yet you
have privileged kids in Overland
swathmore Harvard Yale they think they
are victims that have to be protected
from the the girls think that to protect
from the boys on their campus who may
they act as though they are these lethal
oppressors I think most of that is BS to
respectfully not not wait but these
girls like I just had a girl was talking
with not Kay Jarrett about this we both
know her and she was talking about a guy
okay let me give you a story an anecdote
to so that then you can take it home
here this guy we know very nice guy okay
he's he's like just a quintessential
surfer nicest guy you know he really
liked my wife's friend she's very
attractive
he liked her a lot she didn't like him
but he was constantly pursuing her
buying her flowers it was we called him
the stoner gentleman because he's a
surfer but he was very very into her
she's very attractive
this other girl who is a monster who
also lives nearby claims that he groped
her now she is the exact opposite type
and this guy has no history of that at
all he's we know that he's actually
worked as a babysitter and he didn't do
that to the girl that we know he liked
the girl who was unattractive who would
not stand a chance in hell of being
groped by this guy he's creepy he was
all over me I think there's a lot of
that on campus I think Trigg Lee puff is
more likely to say someone groped her
than someone who's more likely to be
groped yeah well you think is we don't
know and the problem is young women are
be
taught to interpret innocent overtures
or someone just telling a joke or say
you know giving a compliment they're
being taught to view that as some kind
of transgression and it when I years ago
well not got Munir and a few years ago
when I would talk about these issues it
was a small percentage of women who had
taken one too many women's studies
courses they believed the propaganda and
they became somewhat fanatical yes what
worries me is it's now spread because
too many young women they believe this
misinformation we have to go to a brick
I want this is the first I want to keep
you on straight into the next hour
because I love where you're going one
women study course some could argue is
one too many in today's role Chris
christina hoff sommers
back at the top of the hour a lot of
with Crowder you change that channel
will beat you
[Music]
we're bringing new who moi we will
Crowder I'm powering [ __ ] we thank you
now back to our field reporter Jimmy who
is in rough shape Jimmy last time we
left you how has the situation drained
it hasn't really changed much I didn't
drink the water so thanks for that but
you still don't have any eyes or limbs
so well you knew what you signed up for
when you volunteered for Flint Jimmy I
need you to let us know what's happening
on the ground okay unless they knew
there was a protest and President came
in I'm getting dizzy I'm losing a lot of
blood here generally no I needed to stay
professional okay no one said this would
be easy stay on task quadriplegic damn
it Jimmy this is why you've never been
promoted from field reporter treant like
as a serious job
[Music]
all right always with the dancing this
is a classy lady back going into the
second hour had to have her factual
feminist on YouTube Twitter well we've
done all the plugs you know where to
find her
christina hoff sommers don't need to
call you doctor we did we had a guy at
my high school quit a doctorate PhD in
philosophy and his name was mr. Matt he
made you call him dr. manky and if you
didn't he would make you write an essay
and he got kicked out I think for being
verbally abusive guy was a pompous ass
so that's why I asked and we used to
prank call him and we would never do
this with it but because he was he would
make everyone call him doctor we used to
prank call him leave voicemails on his
machine like asking him for medical
advice and he didn't find it funny yes
yes we did half the recurring characters
people see in my channel where
characters we used to make prank calls
with to work on your tow women who go
into these you know women's studies and
they become fanatical you know a couple
of things there is there any way to do
you think we're the point what's even
possible to teach women studies and not
make fanatical feminists do you think
there's any opening there for people
like you who are actual feminists to be
a constant president presence on campus
not just speakers do you think that ship
has sailed
it's complicated because I'll make a few
distinctions there are women studies
professors who are legitimate they teach
women in literature they teach women in
Medieval Valencia I don't know they're
specialists on women and they abide by
the protocols of you know professional
historiography they are serious scholars
mm-hmm however they are accompanied by a
large sort of profession without
professional but what I would call you
know feminist theorists experts on
feminist theory what is feminist theory
no one is no one outside a little
coterie of like-minded people takes it
seriously it has not been cropped
evaluating and if you do try to evaluate
it and you're outside the sisterhood
you're called a backlash er and a crank
so great is that an actual term they use
crank yeah
the term backlash er like I always just
get you have a penis you can't have an
opinion so I don't hear the inside lady
terms well these are just words I don't
know that's a common like label you know
like like you know trans Fobo is a label
or social justice worry I don't know if
like crank or backlash er was a hashtag
for like people of you and some you know
what I said it I mentioned that
dissident feminists like myself and
their Camille poly uh there are others
know reddit court keV and Katie Roy yeah
I said we're not typically taught in the
classroom and then a woman said oh yes
one of my professors put all your essays
together in the library and we could go
and look at it it was under label
backlash and then they they shipped it
aside to make room for Naomi Wolf yeah
they still read her I think if they read
it doesn't matter it could be a wolf or
it could be a scholar the scholars are
ideologues yeah the feminist theorists
yes and they are carried away with with
these false information about how
America you know women live in a state
of siege it's almost as the better
things get for women in the United
States the angrier they get and they
they will not admit that most of the
things they fought for not all but most
those battles have been fought and won
yeah we don't take yes for an answer
well the problem is now there's going to
be backlash from a lot of young men
because they've been vilified you can
only say that they're you know only
paint them as rapists and sexual
predators and that was the point I met
mate listen I don't know a single man
and if they are they're in hiding no one
in my circle of influence or friends who
they by the way I was raping this broad
and they expect us to be like yeah
that's that's Tuesday every one of us
hates rape
hey hey rapist as much as women if not
more right to say that America and if
you find out it's somebody attacked and
it harmed a woman the instinct of most
Americans and people I hope it most
everywhere the interests is to find that
person and we feel sometimes yes and
pray on it just seems it's a crime that
is revile well that was my instinct with
you with the verbal assault and then I
was conflicted because I wasn't quite
sure if it was a man or a woman verbally
assault and you cite I didn't know
exactly what to feel and that was my my
dad's instinct and if you look at the
comments that's the vast majority of the
male commenters instinct going
I don't even agree with her but she
seems so nice like she could be my mom
it just really really disgusts me that
they would treat her this way that's the
mainstream reaction of men and it they
hear from their feminist teacher or
their their girlfriend about all these
men that are doing these terrible things
and they may think back and they
remember they once knew someone and so
they take it seriously but I urge all
those young men to think about your
friends think about your father think
about your brothers does that describe
them do they man don't the average man
does not want in in the United States
does not want to attack or harm a girl
no I'm gonna be there friends they like
them yes and they they want to have
sexual relations with them yeah well I
don't know at this point it's almost you
know if it's just a just in advance with
a woman is considered if it's considered
harassment it's so broadly defined there
are and some of this is the agreement
not it what's happened is that we have
this axis of intolerance you have the
the somewhat fanatical feminist
theorists then you have the students who
become extra zealous but now they are
empowered by administrators who were
given the go-ahead by the both the
Justice Department in the United States
and
Department of Education so we we have
this propaganda campaign driving
government policy which is making the
fanaticism on campus worse yeah I don't
know eventually it's all gonna fall down
but it's very unfortunate it's you know
and it's also unfortunate because there
are victims of sexual violence on campus
most of the victims are off campus the
if you look at the best data we have
women who in poor neighborhoods are far
more at far greater risk than girls that
yeah it's you you know universities
these prestigious colleges anecdotally
anecdotally because you're presenting
office is the factual information but
anecdotally I know probably I probably
know for girls who claimed they were
raped I know one person who was actually
raped it was devastating it was life
destroying and the other person some of
these two of the other people dated the
guys again who they claimed raped them
now doesn't mean it didn't happen no but
if I'm gonna put the Vegas betting odds
on it it was a very different reaction
from someone who I knew was actually
raped and that was what upset me because
I had met these other people beforehand
and when I when I found out this other
person was actually raped it was such a
stark contrast I thought wow it really
belittles what you've gone through well
there are there young women now if they
have a drunken hookup and look back on
it they are encouraged to call that a
rape my wife rapes me all the time then
every now and then we have a too much
wine when we go for a steak dinner and
listen she takes the yeah she takes the
way that's right well it makes most
human intimacy becomes a crime yeah and
and why is it again at that point was
the reverse discriminant a thing that's
a perfect example if both are drunk why
is one responsible for rape unless it's
predicated and the idea that men are
stronger and more sexually predatory by
nature which they denied the first place
university of virginia with a law
professor and she thought that sex under
the influence of alcohol was you know a
form of sexual assault I said well what
if
two people have had the same amount to
drink and they have sex would you say
they raped each other and I thought that
was a absurd she said yes
well that's the problem with doing
comedy on campus right now and you know
what even going back to them to that
point I knew a guy who when we would go
you know as I was a scene that we were
into you know either punk or hardcore so
we'd go down to the cops I knew we knew
a guy and he was notorious for getting
chicks drunk he wouldn't be as drunk and
take advantage of them and we all hated
that guy I watched that guy get the crap
kicked out of him by someone's sister
that does happen that is a problem that
is wrong but they're tossed into the
same pile the guy who goes out and
deliberately gets women drunk to take
advantage of them he's putting the same
pile as two people who had a couple
extra drink drinks at the pub and
realized they weren't attractive in the
morning right also keep in mind that a
lot of women as I recall being in
college you would sometimes drink to
lower your inhibitions so you could do
crazy things I mean I wanna speak about
my set but it's did that I saw my
friends would drink and so they'd be
less inhibited I think that's a
disclaimer I think you've yes well
that's why you stuck around for stick
around for your PhD because you said hmm
college allows for this kind of a
lifestyle base mom became her screen
name
I'm trig Lee puffs good lord how much
time do we have Jared one minute oh one
minute okay well we don't have a whole
bunch of time it was for me was the most
intense reaction yeah I think it was a
boiling point in murderous with machine
gun and then but somehow this was these
liberals access the machine which
they're handing out Justin back backyard
by the way oh there's no way they can
have a machine gun it is hard I believe
me I'm trying to get a license you have
to go through a whole a whole charade
okay will you come
for this soon will you come back will
you come back on the program soon oh yes
okay good then I don't feel so bad
leaving you high and dry but we have
nicked Apollo to get to next another
wildly offensive comedian factual
feminist
christina hoff sommers thank you so much
and we need to have you back soon like
within the month loaded with Crowder
stay tuned be nice
[Music]
for water with Crowder I'm Perry
Matheson taking you back to our on the
field reporter who will exhibit the
utmost professionalism from here for
won't you hear me of course of course
okay Jimmy you are in Flint and you've
been severely injured who is coming back
Jimmy okay because aware of this
flooding soon as you can Jimmy what's
happening do your job Jimmy what's
happening this is very important as a
field reporter you need to use what you
have available can you tell me what kind
of caliber these bullets penetrating
your flesh feel what we call making an
inference it's required to make quick
decisions on the field Jimmy go with
your gut you just pick those Colin Cowie
were out there there's a lazy reporter
Jimmy I kind of attitude is exactly why
you found yourself removed from the palm
beach assignment and the sign then Flint
why don't you take some time and think
about what Jerry while you're believing
now is self-important law pissant
[Music]
that was a surge of energy that just
came through me I'm big on the cheese
positiveness we don't have that much
time I think to Nick DiPaolo after this
I'm excited it out fangirling it don't
do it Dave never be good want to break
out your Bullwinkle impression so few
people were asking me ben shapiro and my
lawyer Nautilus got into it on Twitter
I shouldn't say got into it I won't want
to be neutral because I like both of
them they were both scheduled to be in
the very first live stream of this show
and it didn't work remember it just it
didn't work we couldn't get them both on
because we didn't have the right tool at
the same time anyways feeling back to
back by the way we also just found out
that not gay Jarrod that there's a
setting that we can change next week so
there should be far fewer complications
as far as buffering for people on
YouTube right once again things that
could have been brought to my attention
yes that is I don't know it is like oh
yeah there's a setting here where we
won't have any more problems so we
apologize if you're listening to rest
really live video stream Thursday nights
so mildly innopolis ben shapiro got into
it on twitter didn't get into it milo
went after Ben that's been happening for
a bit now and I and I like both of them
I obviously performed with Milo as they
were going back and forth on Twitter I
provided this show as an open platform
for them both to debate and people
saying well it's not neutral because you
don't like Trump well you know what it's
true I don't like Trump but if you
listen to my interview with with Ben
I was a little contrarian on the
Michelle fields thing to try and be fair
and the same thing with Milo I've worked
with both of them I consider myself
friends with both of them so I respect
both of them and I think that there are
far more pressing issues than trying to
destroy other very valuable members of
the conservative movement that being
said ben shapiro did accept and i don't
know that milo did to be fair
behind-the-scenes you know their their
contract issues at play
so i don't know i don't want to throw
anyone under the bus or assume why
contract availability right Ben's not
tied down by that it depends on who you
work for in this business so so anyways
so that's the standing offer they're
always welcome to come and air their
grievances and I think would be much
more effective than going back
fourth plus it'd be really entertaining
we'll be really entertaining we were
going to do it a long time ago while
they were still more so friends and now
it's is just it's it's just listen
they're both very good in their
verticals Milo is a is a very
entertaining provocateur he knows how to
manipulate not manipulate he knows how
to work media he understands the
showmanship he's also of course very
intelligent Ben Shapiro is a hyper ly
informed and I guess credentialed you
would say lawyer debater did it like
that's kind of his thing
yeah so they're both very good and what
they do and I think they're both that
they both serve a role and Ben's but
it's also valuable II jus II him which
is it's helpful sometimes Ben needs you
know I don't like I just turned down the
jus mess it's really not what was that
movie for your consideration Christopher
Guest film okay so I do want to talk
about something this was a minister
there's so many stories to get to oh my
gosh and we have to get to Nick DiPaolo
so a couple things taught target stock
dropped over four points Albany the hate
crime member we talked about that was
proven to be a hoax those race-baiting
Murad's
have been indicted we had a story up
there on facebook censoring
conservatives we know that I want to
talk about something this happened at a
Walmart this video went viral of a woman
berating a guy in a line in front of her
using an EBT card now if you read the
article there's a lot of nuance there
and people just commented on the title
so I figured I'd expand upon this on the
program Jared let's roll that clip
all right there we go so that is very
telling now do I think she's a shrew and
she's out of line for chewing out a guy
in front of his kids yes so I think he's
out of line to be a full-grown man with
kids wearing a Cannibal Corpse t-shirt
yes do I think that yes for always yes
but he was very telling he goes on in
that video it's a ladder with Crider
calm he goes on to tell her well yeah of
course of course of course I'll take
advantage of the system
he says vote Republican what does that
mean hey if you don't like me taking
your stuff vote Republican now I wrote
about this she's out of line he's out of
line let me get to the spirit of this
however there was a time where people
felt shame taking stuff from other
people there was a time where welfare
was available I talked about this Jimmy
Braddock you've seen probably Cinderella
man it's a true story he took welfare he
had to pass the Hat he felt so ashamed
about it and I'm not saying you should
feel that that ashamed about it there's
somewhere in the middle some shame is
good that he returned the welfare money
was back on top this is an FDR Irish
Catholic Democrat New York Jimmy
Braddock he returned the welfare money
the Spirit is different if someone has
helped down on their luck versus this
guy now vote Republican and you're not
gonna win so I'm gonna keep taking your
stuff someone asked me on Twitter this
was this happened on Twitter today
well I took I work 40 hours a week and I
take I take food stamps to pay for my
kids does that make me less of a man
yes pretty much yeah
now what why well one of the most
masculine qualities and certainly one of
the most attractive qualities to members
of the opposite sex is the ability to
provide think about that for a second
men look for women with big boobs with
birthing hips they look for a trip why
lactation the ability to give them
healthy offspring men are sexually
attracted to physical traits they're
attracted to warmth they're attracted to
a mothering nature period that's reality
women are attracted to strength they're
attracted to men who seem like they can
provide men who can take care of the
flock that's why
like big muscles that's why they like
confidence that's why they like people
who are funny is is is something
generally until he can do the whole
cerebral comedians now like oh I'm just
so miserable one point the guy who was
funny was the guy in the room who could
hold court funny confident strong men
that's what women like not being able to
provide and doing so rightfully as very
unmasked Yulin he'll get really mad do
you think it makes me less of a man for
taking money for yes I think you
probably shouldn't have those kids I
think you should decide beforehand and
then if you're there I think you find a
way and I think that if you do need to
take a handout at some point you do so
quietly and you do it for as short of a
time as possible am I wrong tweet me at
s credit it's not that I'm not
sympathetic everyone needs help I
understand that it is the spirit of well
I'm just gonna get mine by the way
people talk about how I need that help
why shouldn't I get that help okay I
understand that but why should you take
it from someone else who's working 60
hours a week and doesn't qualify for
those benefits at some point it's coming
from somebody and you're just saying
that it's more fair for you because
you're less successful than the other
guy who might be working more and
putting in more effort so let's not
confuse this with being mean and not
being fair someone's paying for it how
is that fair we have to come back with
the legendary we're gonna do this this
is happening Nick DiPaolo Lauder with
Crowder's stay tuned or you're bad you
suck
[Music]
in the year 2010
now remember sweetheart you can be
whatever you want to be so long as you
put your mind to it does that mean I can
even be a boy Oh Oh dearest no no that
wouldn't be sensible I'm talking real
life the year 2016 see sweetheart you
can be whatever you wanna be so long as
you put your mind to it really even a
boy here's a dick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have well I always say
that but okay this is what let me
introduce this this next guest usually
we give a lot of plugs really obvious he
has a tremendous podcast the Nick
DiPaolo podcast follow him on Twitter at
Nick DiPaolo di p AO l the funniest man
alive for me my opinion I think he is
the funniest man walking granite earth
right now Nick sorry for the borderline
[ __ ] fangirl ISM are you there yeah
introduction there's nowhere to go but
down but did you just say [ __ ] you
could say that interests already know we
can't I can because not gay Jared can
edit it so he can plan for it but you
have to be in a short leash because
we've listened to your podcast
man I mean it's it's one of the I think
we talked about this cuz thank you you
you played this rant but I did it at
UMass and I was unbelievably flattered
because of anything you know I was I was
channeling people from I've grown up on
like like you you've dealt with this
since before I was born
do you feel like it has gotten worse
recently I know you won't do college
campuses but even just in the last few
years because you're known for a guy who
pisses people off that's kind of your
brand I guess does everything can get
touchy or who was it we at honor they
got furious lubricating pocket catheter
because an AM radio those sell like
hotcakes
I want to get the sample kit of
catheters right I heard you can make
farms out of half of them yes I'm
getting my top three down the door yeah
the PC yeah it's cutting its got
progressively work I mean like I told
you I did stand up my first my first Oh
my gig was like a 1987 and after about
my third like probably my third time on
stage somebody goes yeah you're kind of
like politically incorrect that's that's
that's where it's headed and you're in
the right spot and and even then I said
the guy I don't thanks doc thank you and
it's gonna get exponentially worse since
we let women vote but anyway well yeah I
know I don't know um you know you know
it's funny we've talked about that not
to get off the comedy thing but you know
most women didn't want the right to vote
did you know that right yeah you know
why because back then to vote you you
were a part of the draft bucket duty was
voluntary firefighter service so it was
like 70 something butts despite what
Meryl Streep will tell you in her
academy worthy performance which they
claimed every single one is most women
did not want to vote because it was seen
as a privilege that came with
responsibilities and and women didn't
want it a lot when I said that to the
ticket holder a member at a movie
theater in Suttons Bay she swore up and
down I was lying to her until I brought
it up on my phone 100% no no I think I
think you're right though something like
I don't know it's women weren't voting
if they didn't have the vote Republicans
would have won every election except the
one since the Eisenhower administration
something probably and and I tell you
what I know
well get a Trump is not gonna I'm not
gonna help Republicans with that right
now that's kind of his Achilles heel but
back to the comedy thing you know it's
funny you said that you sort of I would
think that in 87 it was certainly more
open that was part of my rant right even
if you look at the hippies back then
they at least sort of tried to feign
like they were fighting for free speech
kids on college campus right now you
know not only were they not even there
for 9/11 neck so this is even for me
what just a few years removed it's just
sort of been assumed but well hate
speech isn't acceptable offensive speech
isn't acceptable it's not even an issue
to them it's just assumed yeah we have
to limit speech so I yeah I gotta
imagine from 87 to there too stark
contrast there opera and 9/11 kinda with
the views like that it kind of makes you
wish they were
or third floor doing some banking in the
sunglass hut God we're gonna get letters
they've been brainwashed if you watch
movies from the 80s
you can see the the liberal jerk-offs
who make film at work that's when it
started to take over the politically
correct messages in movies right watch
watch Philadelphia with Tom Hanks ya
want the an attack on old white men and
not to mention Olmos not to mention all
those silly little romantic comedies
that bloomed in the mid-80s just lost a
politically correct nonsense that's I
thought sure was happening before that I
mean Hollywood's always people but
that's when I even noticed you know well
I think you're right about the 80s
because right Reagan Hollywood sort of
fancies itself as anti-authoritarian
though right now you know they are the
man they're the media they're the
entertainment industry and they have the
White House and for several years they
had House of Representatives I mean at
the supermajority but you know in the
80s with Reagan I think they had free
rent like the imperfect samples
Philadelphia the AIDS thing it was never
an epidemic was never an epidemic that
your chances of getting AIDS unless
you're shooting dirty needles and having
gay orgies in a truck stall are
statistically less than 0% in the United
States they always have been and healthy
Haitian choreographers and a lot of
rugged construction material that's kept
me doing radio in my basement the last
years but uh you know ya know it's all
I'm just more tired of it it doesn't
even faze me now it's like yeah you know
I I guess I just plow ahead and I mean
Trump look I'm not a huge fan and stuff
right but you know he's sort of one knee
old just with a set of balls on him I
was half asleep on the couch you know
six months ago and instead of he was
imitating that that reporter from New
York Times's just disabled guy whatever
I I almost fell off the couch laughing
oh no not that I want to make fun of
physically challenged people I'm just
saying isn't right
yeah that's an endorsement business this
is precisely why you know uh unlike Nick
I've kind of been sucked into this
political sphere and he's really done
more say more in the comedy side I feel
like why don't you endorse someone
because of what you just said there's so
many quotes like that from me they can
trudge up and ever like this man who
played spot the transsexual on April 3rd
endorsed you mr. Rubio or whoever it is
no I you know you know it's my I don't I
don't like Trump because I think
especially as community comedians know
an authoritarian a guy who's alluded to
cracking down on free speeches is a
problem for guys like you and me and you
know all of a sudden if you don't like
him that's you know it's a but I like
like you said that the things that I
don't like about him have nothing to do
with the reasons the media hate him that
he makes fun of somebody or he says
build a wall or he said you know buzz
loves our problem none of those things
bother me but it's it's the free speech
issue means a comedian does that make
you a little uneasy when you see him
talking about libel laws with the press
and really just anyone he doesn't like
it seems as the umbrella sort of
definition yeah I think you would have a
hell of a time pass the most libel law
although you know who knows he could
pull an Obama who just passed that but
he wants to play king for at that right
but just him you know just him saying
that Hillary if she was a guy should be
five then that is to me that is so
refreshing and just I'm splashing around
in it no I just it's just so refreshing
right now wait wait that's calling us
fat and ugly I mean I can't wait to
mister it's gonna be like Godzilla purrs
mightyjoyoung miss it she's not in jail
right well they could both be in some
serious legal trouble right before well
before November I mean they both have
lost
they both she is indictment here's some
big lawsuits right has Trump you and now
raping a young I don't think it's true
this is the first time though two
presidential candidates could be either
indicted or just the best of America
right there
I believe it's come to this you say rate
yeah you even heard heard that he was
like you this this this a gang rape for
an underage girl I don't think there's
any truth to it just like the Ted Cruz
Affairs but there is a lawsuit right now
on Trump for rape yeah and went about
surface eight minutes ago yeah about a
couple couple of days ago no I came up
before Indiana I don't think it's true
at all but out you know I try and be
consistent right yeah God that was one
of the well yeah that's right you're in
New York and and every time those come
out they're almost always verifiably
proven false I believe we would have
heard about this rape charge last year
when he announced he was running
what was the hesitation no just the
lawsuit I think was just filed and
that's what I do think it's politically
motivated absolutely yeah well that's
the same thing with the Cruz Affairs
which then you know went away anybody
really delayed to a chick bang well I
mean look at Arnold who your pics or
Tiger Woods like sometimes it's not even
about attraction like Arnold just like
went with this this lady who deliver
yeah I know but it's he's the ugly one
Cruz in this equation yeah but men are
you I don't but that would be even less
right because women as long as you're
powerful whereas with Arnold you like
when apathy arena or running together
because long as they're not sleeping
child yeah I know I don't think anyone
does I actually think for what is she's
65 certainly better-looking than Hillary
she stays more fit well it's what you
said about Hillary because we wrote an
article not long ago and we did that you
know the Obama the red and blue sign we
put Hillary's face in there and we put
it on a wall and I said [ __ ] right
underneath Hillary and the article was
[ __ ] will become the new
remind everyone said well you're just
saying socialist because you want to say
the n-word and when we released this
what was this year and maybe eight
months ago even conservatives were oh I
can't were outraged and when we released
it recently same post met to fanfare
from both the right and the left so
there it's the same thing we just
re-released it and people were no longer
offended now unlike sir no one knows I
like sir do you feel that in the in the
in the you know you're more in the
comedy club circuit still these days do
you feel even with fellow comedians like
Hillary Clinton has kind of kind of like
their George Bush where a lot of is
indefensible and and they're not really
big fans they just feel they have to
pull that lever I don't like anybody in
my business but I wouldn't have a 12
Hillary the B word that's I might drop a
seat on her well okay all right your
farm we're far more tasteful and I
there's a even the last few months and I
don't know so I think some of that is
due to Trump and I think like you said
there are a lot of people like you out
there who are just tired you can only
call people racist sexist homophobic
transphobic is a new thing for so long
until they go alright let's go with that
and they're fine with it
well Trump Aziz look you can only
trample on the working-class for so long
and they didn't working-class dish an
example forty years in this country
before they finally react and this is
what you're watching with with Trump
getting all the support you know they
finally that finally strike back you can
only piss on somebody for so long so um
it's refreshing I actually you know he
act some you know and like I said a lot
of Thompson even before he started to
run when I would see him on the
apprentice or on TV in it that you I
would go how is this guy doing there he
won me over would would just go on hey I
have high political correctness and
that's what that's why he's doing as
well as he did yeah well he's doing that
that's what it's about it's about the
culture it's about working-class white
guys tired of being called bigoted
racist this is a reaction right I hope
not the temporary one I hope with the
tsunami
right over times this crap I am so sick
of
listen if the black locks matters and
now walking on that note we're gonna
bring you right back after the break cuz
I wanted to talk about that Nick DiPaolo
stay tuned funniest man walking
[Music]
and now for Donald Trump unify is the
GOP okay frankly his dad was here when
they killed Kennedy I don't know what I
was talking about this okay he's dead
practically pulled the trigger they said
it was a second shooter okay I don't
know this for a fact I pretty sure his
Ted Cruz is dead by the way here's a
wife you should have face look at that
face look at that face
Ted look at the face of your wife you
know I can't believe the face oh it's
terrible the face and the winner of the
Indiana primary is Donald Trump that's
great thanks voters are gonna make
America great again hey Ted we're good
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to be back with our next
guest we have to play those silly bumper
music and I know for him he's like he's
so used to doing all the morning shows
with a toilet flush sound or something
like that
the comedians you have to do this
forever and we don't want to we don't
want to do that to him but Nick DiPaolo
follow him on Twitter Nick DiPaolo
podcast whenever I see people sending
screenshots and they're subscribed to me
they go who else should i subscribe to
right a little move subscribe to Nick's
thing Nick thanks for being with us you
mentioned black lives matter before he
went to the break this is a big shift
when I was at not UMass before that rent
I was at Cal Poly and we had bomb
threats and we had to have cops go
through black lives matter showed up and
in the paper they they fact checked my
jokes and asked me to check my privilege
[Music]
I'm absolutely serious and here's the
thing unit you know Nick late for all
this stuff right at UMass right we've
sort of talked about this where they
outright protest at least you know where
you're aiming right but they come up and
they were dead quiet and they had their
phone on and every time it would make a
joke well you can't see me that's right
because you you don't like the the
skypes so um every time that would make
a joke they would shake their head no
like five people in the front row just
to make everyone uncomfortable laughing
and then they wrote in the paper that I
don't know something I said was
inaccurate about black history which it
most likely was because it was a joke
yeah this this happens all the time it
happened in in in clubs before this
certainly in Canada because they don't
really have freedom of speech do you do
you think it's just college campuses or
orgies
I mean you're big enough where you'll do
kind of theatres on your own right now
so do you think well no I did one in
Staten Island but there you know Staten
Island they call it some Staten Island
it's like I think it might have been I
think it was a DeVry it was nobody
complained but I could never do that I
would never go near a college campus
with that type of song atmosphere really
well we're answering to young black
college students on what we can and
can't say really well I mean yeah I mean
you're white
so that's just kind of how it's supposed
to be set up right now but even in
comedy clubs I mean you have a lot of
Booker's you've got you gotta be honest
you have to be honest with black people
this is a new generation of black people
who don't the black people my age right
to know where you stand
they like the crazy white comic who is
speaking it's mine
right oh in Arlington Virginia past
weekend it was a black I read the middle
I mean would look do rag on oh he was do
you I was playing for him I was feeding
off his energy the whole time right
laughing it and the more honest those
being the harder he was laughing came up
to me after the show that he tweeted me
and this is true in my 28 years don't
stand up I swear to god I've had maybe
10 10 10 black people walk out because
they you know on my show cuz they
thought as if it has opposed to it I'm a
kidney it's hundreds in hundreds of
white young kids right yeah I know see
they're the ones that get offended for
the guy though I have had people
outright get sometimes you do have black
well again it's a generational thing
black people get ultra-sensitive with it
I mean what do you think someone like I
hate to you know you obviously can't
speak from but you were so close and a
lot of you were with Patrice O'Neal what
he wasn't around for the the black lives
matter right and you were constantly
ribbing each other on tough crowd it was
constantly a racial joke or you're a [ __ ]
and you know you're a Jew what do you
think you would have thought of black
lives matter he what I hated it he would
have hated cuz I just said he and some
young kid some young black comic came up
to me like three months ago in a club
here in New York and the King said he
was from Philly I mean like 20 years old
and he comes on he introduces himself
and he goes yo man I met Patrice O'Neal
a couple years ago and he said he was
straight-up gangster when it came to
calm means I don't know what that means
I don't use Skype very often Crowder no
matter who's sitting in the crowd right
like like Hillary you know at that black
radio station saying that she had hot
sauce oh my gosh we
and we have met Anna Lou Blair morphine
drip that's the best way to lose well
she was pandering everybody in the room
know it when they said what are you
carrying a purse they would have had
more respect for her if she said well
thanks to your people I carry mace and
you know and they want to lap their ass
off and it's not the same man it's not
the same and then the black people you
grew up with you know they were right
their parents if not them you know they
at least understood the civil the civil
rights movement there was some kind of a
struggle these kids have none of that
and they're more offended than ever
that's the odd thing I think that not
obviously not numbing an old joke
because you're older than me but people
even just five years old we grew up with
that's because nothing in the way of
pain right would you stay off college
campuses I wish you didn't just because
they need to hear what you have out
there and I think there's an entire
generation of kids who would love it
because they're tired of it too again
they're the silent majority like if I
understand this about UMass right that
was maybe I've heard as low as seven
hundred as high as a thousand like eight
hundred people in there it's 29,000
students maybe forty or fifty of them
were disruptive and yelling like that at
wrigley puffs who she's infamous how
she's a mostly known and they just
scream the loudest the other people were
cheering and drowning them out I think
you'd be surprised
it's a horrible dynamic for comedy
that's a whole different dynamic if
you're up there trying to do an hour by
yourself you know unless you're policing
the room and they're voting people which
they're not gonna because then somebody
will file IO lawsuit but uh on a college
campus but yeah you can't you can't go
you know be a headliner and up there by
yourself and and have people yelling
crap out I mean you you can because
you're nicked Apollo and in your yeah
any funny people anybody can go up
and and any comic who's with donut as
long as I have and just you know
verbally destroy people who are running
this show but that's not what the rest
of people can know exactly it's
disrespectful the audience you're right
but okay well you know what let's do it
let's do a couple minutes in a web
extended you're not gay Jared because I
think I think Nick will we'll be able to
throw some the leash off and people
listening dress really can go to ladder
with Carter come and hear this but Nick
stay right here Nick DiPaolo podcast
everyone else go online
[Music]
and now for Donald Trump unifies the GOP
okay Leslie frankly you got this guy
okay dr. Fred Carson I don't even know
if he's a doctor
okay look at Jersey there's no degree
for his doctor the only thing okay
truthfully I think he's a doctoring is
big pathological okay like a pedophile
you can't cure pathological this this
guy okay dr. ben Carson nice guy he's a
pedophile okay let's just go a little
kids I don't know what I would never
said it about that's what the kids are
screwed that's what they say they say
dr. ben Carson all he does is he hey you
know it does of the brain surgery okay
truthfully now what he's not a school
little kid the winner of the Indiana
primary is Donald Trump
that's great things this is a great
victory for America okay hey dr. Carson
all water under the bridge
[Music]
I
[Music]
- struggling
Oh glad to be back that was Nick DiPaolo
always and we have Gerald Morgan coming
on after the the next break
so I'd adapted to people I had to change
my shirt that shirt that I was wearing
earlier producing with me in studio as
always is not gay Jerrod follow him at
not cage here it on Twitter for the
medical applications try your own
conclusions the shirt had one of those
it wasn't a tag you know where it says
the material and it was just it was big
and into me I had to take it all that I
wanted to be professional for the the
newer guests but now I just as something
comes don't care that shirt was just it
was it was making the noise and I had to
roll it up because it had them what's
that we kind of yes Skype Skype call
coming in who's skyping us cane 1880
there yeah hey hey hey good hey were do
nam we're gonna show him call you call
you back later okay I am but I'm we're
busy tell us we're doing a show yeah
yeah we're live though Rex you live so
can we come back later tell him we're
doing we're doing a show right now I
just clicked I got to go hang up gotta
go sorry I don't know how often does
that happen that pretty often them I saw
me was there didn't he visit you and
you're in hospital
he did he did he got on the show because
you knew him before we ever worked
together in the show and I won't stop it
just keeps calling well just make sure
you know the show it's a fine he's a
good guy hey by the way we had some
polls out earlier over two thousand
people have answered in in less than an
hour Trump versus Hillary what are you
doing 48% have said Trump negligible
three percent said Hillary but 34
percent said third party and 15% said
fluoride in your tap exclamation
exclamation exclamation that's a valid
option we need to stop put out as
options on there because I think it's
use the results the fact that it's
pretty close between Trump and
third-party it's a scary thing the GOP
may well I've seen a lot of people
talking about evidence we have Austin
Peterson on last week people talking
it's kind of a tempting option now that
no you know
or about them I mean it's a protest vote
yeah it's not really gonna go anywhere
but it could you know down the line
right push the bar a little bit but I
want to get to as someone was asking me
one of our fans here on Twitter asked me
about the alt right what is your opinion
of it but we've talked about it before
there are some good people and there are
some bad people in every movement I I
think when you start getting to the
point where you're you're emailing the
the Nazi propaganda to ben shapiro you
go from being a disturber to if your
goal is offense being offensive is a
perfectly acceptable delivery mechanism
this is what I've always said and
obviously I've offended a lot of people
I'm fine with that if your goal is
offense in and of itself it just means
you're a hack and someone like like Nick
who's one of the best comedians ever
would tell you that and he's as
offensive as they come but you can find
offensive people at an open mic so my
whole thing with people online trolls I
understand that it can be used very well
and very effectively and I'm not morally
against it but if your end goal is did
you see how much o2 a person and that's
it I mean you can do it obviously I
didn't have a lot of respect for you as
a performance artist as a comedian as an
activist you're just a hack not saying
the entire alt-right is that way one
thing I will say is I really do
appreciate our fans we have very loyal
fans they go online they create the
memes but there we have a pretty
informed fan base I'm not worried about
them trying to dock somebody they'll
argue with people I mean they've been
blocked by people like Amy Schumer one
of a PC principal or farty farty and Jim
one of them Chewbacca's lover I don't
know which one was blocked by Amy you
know one of them hasn't been blocked by
Shaun King and was upset by it they're
smart and most of them petitioned to get
me fired it's true so it's there's smart
Aaron balance there instigators but they
they are they still have a semblance of
humanity so we appreciate them and they
make fun of us the most to be honest you
just most of all speaking of making fun
of people who may or may not be gay and
we don't know where they stand Caitlyn
Jenner posing will be on the cover of
Sports Illustrated
nude with an American flag and Bruce
Jenner's medals um there you go
my Christmas Eve
came early first off I don't know how
they what they do with the airbrushing
the bits and pieces no nude little belly
that's rocket manse where you put the
medals just kind of just cover them
tastefully like the old bull tasteful
nudity kind of like you do with the old
Greek statues and the leaf yeah with a
little tasteful little little percenters
only they are metals that Caitlyn Jenner
never won this is what's so silly about
it Caitlyn Jenner has the exact same
amount well less of athletic
accomplishments as I do particularly if
you play by the whole transgender LGBTQA
IP and a silent F rules right this is a
new person Peru sizzle watch the show
watch the I am Kate show you know our
Bruce is someone all mesh and and versus
someone in the past but this is you know
I'm Caitlyn now I'm a whole new person
nothing yes you are you're the only
person well then sorry you don't get to
carry over medals if I win a gold medal
I have the hiccups if I win a gold medal
scare me
I can take my I'm taking my clothes off
okay well kid hiccups are gone they're
gone if I win gold medals they don't go
to not gay Jared Bruce Jenner wins
medals they don't go to Caitlyn Jenner
this isn't about intolerance these are
the same people who by the way will get
absolutely furious and and and want to
strip athletes of metals for using
performance-enhancing drugs well let's
do the reverse do you think Caitlyn
Jenner could win anything in any
category under the hormone replacement
therapy nomination the added weight I
mean you trying to lean down as a
decathlete you're adding a couple of
pounds of rubberized gelatinous goo get
there's that either word
there's no way Caitlyn Jenner's when
winning any kind of an athletic endeavor
there is no consistency whatsoever with
the transgender thing and you know we
never want to speak ill of former
employers of course so but people ask me
about the PJTV thing and actually there
are a lot of great friends at PDT you
just made me think about it because
we're talking about the trans thing and
it made me think about lamb and fun dip
who got furious for people who listen
when the show started he was my producer
and how mad he would get about the trans
stuff and there was never any
consistency there was never any
consistency he was a perfect emblem of
you know
just you couldn't argue there was no
logic just whatever people want whatever
they feel whatever their soul says so
now Caitlyn Jenner wants to steal Bruce
Jenner's medals don't you thought of
ironic that for first wrong now feminist
she built all of her fame off the man he
built it off the back of [ __ ] well
there you go yeah now what do you mean
[ __ ] I mean they have sex on camera
for money yeah well I guess that's its
kind of Alan who get mad all the time at
that like why you can't use what you
can't [ __ ] shame are you [ __ ] maybe you
should be shamed oh I guess that's kind
of self induced isn't it do you feel bad
about yourself I do a little bit well
there you go your mom raised you very
poorly Caitlyn Jenner get a tweet me at
s Crowder what you think I I just it's
one of those deals where there is no
logic to this issue and you want to talk
about the social justice leftism trig
Lee puff by the way I think we have the
best video and wriggly puffs that the
internet will see on Monday not to tease
you but it might be Tuesday morning but
I think you're gonna look forward to it
if you want more trickling puffs I was
talking about there's someone asks me I
remember who it was recently this week
saying well why do you think that
they're also you know the transgender
thing the bathroom deal black lives
matter they're always very disruptive
and pretty violent you know leftist
Occupy Wall Street black lives matter at
our rally yelling cussing swearing
whereas the tea party they left places
cleaner than they found them whether you
like it or not generally conservative
protests have not been violent
conservative protests and it's it's it's
something really simple it kind of hit
me we'll think about it for a second big
government socialism the only way to
make that work when you boil it down is
through violent force coercion
that's the only way when people are
saying the People's Revolution it needs
to be fair well how are you gonna do it
we're gonna take their stuff what if
they don't want to do that but we're
gonna force them what if they say I'm
not giving you 65 percent of what I've
earned the real answer we're going to
send in people who are armed to take it
and put them in jail the real answer is
unlike capitalism unlike free enterprise
which can only function
through voluntary transaction again the
the tree let's get to the center of this
right the the tree trunk gosh I was like
stump no because that's a dead tree tree
trunk is violence that's the root of
liberalism that's root of socialism
communism centralized government they
can only take it through force so of
course it stands to reason that the
people who are protesting who are out
there getting what they want they're
using the same technique that they
believe government should do which is
take it by force you don't like someone
else's speech take it by force shaking a
little teacher arm fat little Occupy
Wall Street we believe the government
should redistribute it okay well you're
in the wrong part of Zuccotti Park here
in New York I'm gonna drop a deuce in
someone else's tent the roots of
liberalism people on it at the end of
the day it can only be accomplished
through violence that's the ultimate
threat that's not necessary for
capitalism what is necessary for
capitalism not talking crony capitalism
is a voluntary transaction the only way
you succeed is if someone wants your
good goods your product your service and
so when you think it when you go okay
this is the trunk of the tree the
branches coming off it makes sense that
they're inherently more violent than
conservatives that leftist are that way
that they throw these temper tantrums
that they throw rocks through windows
that they burn down cities because at
the end of the day they're doing this
because they want a system of government
that effectively would have to do the
same thing to accomplish what they want
take your pick anything anything
anything that Bernie Sanders problem
free college we're gonna took the money
I'm gonna take that money from the
Cayman Islands how eventually walk down
the line government force it's not
peaceful for all the peaceful hippies of
love man at the end of the day you were
advocating forcibly taking other
people's things that they have
rightfully earned and we're going to do
a video rebuttal on on the karl marx
video that has been circulating because
he was trending today it is one of those
things where I'm amazed that we're in a
generation people actually praised Karl
Marx I'm also amazed that Caitlyn Jenner
apparently gets to take Bruce Jenner's
medals a chick gets to take
guy's medal for winning a guy's division
and if you say hey that's kind of weird
Plus Caitlyn still has a pecker it's
hate speech welcome to 2016 welcome to
2016 so I if it seems like I'm not able
to make sense of that it's because I'm
not I I if someone wants to come on the
program and present a valid case as to
Caitlyn Jenner's athletic
accomplishments I am all ears and boobs
and wiener because I can have all of
them Gerald Morgan rocket scientist
doctor after the break stay tuned
[Music]
hopper takeover of the louder with
Crowder channel here I did not want to
do this but I had no other way left with
what I believe most Americans and their
canine counterparts find to be
unsatisfactory candidates for president
I would like to announce that I am
beginning offers exploratory committee
for a president my formal announcement
of candidacy policies will come in the
following weeks but I can tell you that
a hopper platform without a doubt will
provide full rights under the law for
everyone and sardines and all the
cheese's for all the peoples and dogs
but not the cats also I have very
thorough plans for what to do with the
current squirrel infestation I think
you're gonna like it
so stay tuned akka church
[Music]
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
Twitter at s Crowder where I'm tweeting
all day long I'm ticking off the social
justice warriors you should see the
amount of hate I get on there
far far far worse than any fad Sports
Illustrated model or black lives matter
charlatan so listen it's free you get to
be entertained and you can chime in also
if you're following me on Twitter you
can send me your tweets and maybe you'll
be lucky enough and I mean lucky enough
because I have a lot of followers okay
that they call me the follower machine
to have your tweet to me or not gay
Jared included in our rockingest tweet
of the week so follow me on twitter at s
Crowder if not I don't want to say I
have sites on your mother but oh she's
dead you're just saying that because I
made a mom joke no she's really dead
well you kind of walk it
[Music]
you
[Music]
we're back with our guest that was very
poor dancing to people watching in the
video studio well it's embarrassing for
all it was supposed you know the Muppet
dance but and this next guest is not a
fan of the Muppets but he is a very
accomplished neurosurgeon rocket
scientist I think he has three PhDs
three now I thought I thought I heard
four on the street they could before I
think you've added Gender Studies but
he's a very learned man and we're we are
fortunate to be graced with his presence
you can follow him at G Morgan Jr Gerald
Morgan are you with us sir I am and in
the immortal words of King prawn what'd
you do what'd you do what'd you do
pepping the king prawn is one actually
it's right I converted Gerald is one of
the funniest characters in all of the TV
film that made the king prawn and jailed
and I remember what I think we were we
had a couple of beers one night we were
watching him up at show so good and it
more interesting yes it made it more
interesting
so okay Gerald you were chomping at the
bit to come onto this Pro usually you
always you ditch us but the audience
likes you because the Trump situation
you were pretty they had even seen them
they've never cease if they've seen they
would really and cut to you if you're
talking they would really be in for a
treat I think it's if they could see
Gerald yes I don't know I mean saying I
have better pictures than the one on
Twitter I mean come on really I think we
gathered the yellow shirt like yeah it's
on purpose I get it yes yes Jerry you
shaming me right now your body shaming
me and I don't like it not well no you
shame yourself sir yeah elbows in public
prints chafing you and I both know you
could put pants on over it this is a
decision you've made and now you have to
live with the consequences and meet the
Internet
so you were upset this week with it with
the Donald Trump Ted Cruz we obviously
know that you don't like Donald Trump I
don't know you often work late into the
evening so I don't know if you saw my
statement early on the fact is rules are
rules and I don't like it but I said hey
you know Donald Trump you won Congrats
on the win and let's see where it goes
doesn't mean that I'm a fan but I feel
like we do have to accept the results if
they go by the rules that we agreed to
beforehand where are you with us yeah
it's like the conventions gonna be the
slow clap that never really takes off
yeah there's gonna be five
I don't know and nobody nobody joins you
know maybe one other guy on the other
side of the arena but I just it wasn't I
mean you and I kind of talked off a line
just a little bit about it you text me
like hey you know everybody's gonna be
pissed to some degree I think you're
right the process is the process my
problem is is just and I hate to say
that your listeners don't really fall
into this category but everybody else if
you're listening to this turn it turn it
up really loud and maybe get a pen
account we're stupid if we think that
these people on both sides are the best
that we've got the very best options for
the greatest country in the history of
the world for these two people to be our
leaders we are absolutely idiots and we
will very quickly find out that we can't
be idiots our entire life and expect to
stay free it just does not happen
history shows us over and over and over
again whenever we start to get high on
ourselves and think that we've got it
all figured out and that we can put
people into power that we like because
they maybe talk to us like a game show
host or somebody who skirts the law and
gets away with it and we're like well
cool they keep getting away with it I
guess I'll reform then we will quickly
find out that our country comes to an
end at some point
it can't happen it never has happened
right straight it won't happen well and
it has to like I said but it sounds like
you're saying when I'm at a certain
point like I said if he got the
delegates he got the number fine or if I
went to a contested convention fine and
here we are other people dropped out I
don't like it just like I don't like the
fact that the Vegas betting odds are
overwhelmingly favor Hillary Clinton but
that's reality and that's why I have a
problem with a never Trump thing even
though long before never Trump existed
long before a lot of these other AM
radio hosts who are on board with Trump
for ratings until they finally decided
to pivot I was Ed I'm not gonna vote for
him I also don't believe in making sure
it's never Trump at the cost of the
process and at the cost of the will of
the people even if they're wrong
absolutely we you and I've talked about
this before in regards to other matters
freedom is always messy but it's always
worth it so we we get the people that
the system gives us because it's more
important that we adhere to the policies
that we put forth in the system then
is do we go oh wait well I don't want
Trump so let's do something underhanded
to get him out I've never been a fan of
Trump I never know frankly I never
thought he'd make it faculy if right yet
frankly it's gonna be huge
I'm sorry you do better that's okay
that's okay you can tell you take the
mic on me but no I yeah listen I've
never been a fan either but you know
this is where we are this is where we're
at
that's that's the reason that I wanted
to say a few things tonight okay we have
to care we have to stop just living our
lives in a way that that really leaves
us with people like this that the only
way that they can grab our attention is
to say something offensive that's the
only way that Trump grabs attention is
by saying something that's offensive to
the majority of people in the country
but we're such I don't know we're so
tuned to entertainment that we retweet
no I don't think I think you're wrong
about that I think people are actually
there refresh that's and I like this
about Trump that he's not afraid to back
something he doesn't back something up
because someone else says it's offensive
and even though I disagree with his
policies III do think more people should
tear a page from that book saying a what
build a wall shouldn't be offensive and
people say it's happens I know it's not
offensive what's offensive to say to
people is like yeah you're all criminals
and we're going to send you all of them
yes absolutely not true oh no absolutely
well no not that what's a what would be
offensive to someone for example I think
listen handshake congratulations
politically from Ted Cruz right to
Donald Trump but Ted Cruz as a man after
Donald Trump's insulted his wife's looks
and said that his dad was involved with
the shooting of JFK he deserves to
deliver an absolute magnificent pecker
punch to Donald Trump in an imp a back
and then okay let's move on with
politics but personally you don't shake
and make up with a guy like that that's
very different from a policy difference
well personally I thought we were better
than the two candidates that it looks
like we're gonna be stuck with on one
side and on the other I don't think
Donald Trump is a serious candidate I
really don't it just seems like he got
in it and all of a sudden was popular
and like well crap now what do I do
I guess I got to get a campaign staff
together you know and do these things
and he may end up being just fine as a
president for a little while but if we
consistently pick people like this to to
represent us we're gonna have a lot of
problems and I I just think that it's
time for us to go okay like this is our
gut-check moment here okay
Donald Trump made it to be the the
promised most people did most people did
even in the Republican Party most people
did not vote for Donald Trump he didn't
ever get anywhere near majority no no no
but the way the system is set up we we
have to mobilize people to go out and
actually vote for a solid candidate we
don't do that right now we go for
ratings people we go for the people that
we see the most because we don't spend
any time digging into who these people
are you explain it a lot on your show on
the podcast we don't put Ted Cruz and
Carly Fiorina and Rubio screwed up and
they've been running it like it's a
campaign in 1996 and they deserve they
deserve to lose they deserve Donald they
deserve to lose now we're gonna have you
back on after the break and it pains me
to say it but I'm tired of all of their
faces at this point people get exhausted
it's because of the way these people
have these incestuous advisers and
strategists we'll talk more about it
after the break Gerald Morgan the most
qualified guy in the show stay tuned
ladder with crowd
[Music]
steven crowder hey Jared what are you
doing I'm just having trouble getting to
this book that's because you can't
really know you shouldn't use freedom
project Academy freedom what freedom
project Academy just go to FPE USA org
it's a fully accredited private online
school
no Common Core and absolutely no
government funding whatsoever all the
classes are taught live online
kindergarten through high school with
real teachers based around the country
so it's your freedom projects classical
curriculum students master the basics
like math English history science along
sets a more commonly neglected courses
like logic you're not getting that in a
lot of schools economics American
Studies in Latin all of which foster the
long lost art of critical thinking and
create leaders for tomorrow all classes
are reported to be viewed 24/7 and you
can get your very own sneak peak of any
class or professor at FPE usa.org open
enrollment runs March through July but
classes always fill up fast now do you
have your GED equivalency Jared knows
that important I think I mean you might
want to give him a call that's freedom
project Academy at FPE usa.org
[Music]
and now for Donald Trump unifies the GOP
okay this is Casey what is he even doing
I don't even know he's there the guy has
no ratings okay yes no pulse guys won
what state okay he's a loser okay listen
I would ever say the guy's got pock
marks okay
so buddy buck bucks you want a president
frankly where's Park box like that he
has pack box okay and he was like that
nobody likes in Ohio his wife doesn't
like them okay I'd say this is what
other people say I think jaw case you
know he's such a bad guy they can't win
a single ball and the winner of the
Indiana primary is Donald Trump eyes
great great nose we're gonna make it
back a great again thank you for
choosing me as your president hey ed
Governor Kasich and still eats you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
all right glad to be back before I bring
on my next guest I'm looking at some of
the tweets a couple of things first
someone said why aren't you a part of
the never Trump movement isn't isn't the
the sentiment the same no I just
explained it I probably will never vote
Donald Trump like I said I reserve the
right to change my mind if you surround
himself with brilliant people I do not
believe in the idea of never Trump at
the cost of integrity of the process and
the party I am NOT never Trump like some
people right now believe in never Trump
even if it means trotting out Mitt
Romney or Paul Ryan I also think just
taking being a joiner in a hash tag as
kind of silly sorry and it's also why
this show has consistently grown what
other people who have taken that
divisive issue and not been reasonable
everyone knows where I stand on that
another one Adam at lunch sack Adam
Anderson thanks for a guess is
overwhelmingly Clinton its 6040 check
predicted org Trump is the people's
choice give him some cred first off 40%
is not the people's choice secondly a 60
to 40 election is exactly what we would
refer to as a landslide 6040 would be a
landslide election those are
unbelievable odds 60 6040 in politics
that is unreal I'm just getting
frustrated people have no idea what
they're talking even even about
five-point difference huge monumental
bringing back of course at G Morgan Jr
Gerald Morgan Gerald is it is it me 6040
split that that that means huge odds and
Hillary's favorite right now thank you
for reading those because you just
proved my point
lots of morons out there who never Trump
but people it's not never Trump we want
the system to survive more than we want
to keep a bad guy like Trump out of
office that's they don't understand that
they're willing to sacrifice all of that
not understanding what will come next
right get rid of this system fine then
you have nothing right they're idiots
I'm sorry both of those were idiots
well of you guys I'm just I'm not saying
you I'm saying you in general you know
not specifically no it's I just want to
clarify my position I you know what I
think it's entirely tenable and logical
you don't have to like the results but
if you sign up for the rules
it's my it was my same problem with
Donald Trump in the delegates he
benefited from the delegate game more
than Annie
got proportionately far more delegates
than he did votes and then it complains
when he loses that bothers me is the
inconsistency from people on the left
and the right and I've never been
inconsistent am i I'm not changing my
personal stance on Trump right
I am your branded as you are because
people want to yell and scream no I'm
not branded that way people are just
asking these questions which are
hopefully clarified listen I clarified
them three to old and white plus
hashtags are silly they're silly you see
someone with a never Trump hashtag in
there in their thing it's just it's I'm
sorry I understand it I understand
supporting Ted but at this point at this
point why at this point what does that
mean never Trump you're just not gonna
vote Trump fine you don't need a hashtag
at this point what you want them to try
it out Paul Ryan or John Boehner I
probably I won't vote Trump unless he
surrounds himself with geniuses I've
said that I've been the most vocal
opponent but right now today May 5th if
you're saying never Trump what are you
saying exactly
I think that's I think I think that's
ultimately my point too yeah but there
are people that are willing to just get
rid of everything because they don't
like the guy I don't like the guy but he
won he's the nominee there's no way
around that he's gonna get the number of
Delegates that he needs case closed
we move on right we're probably looking
at Hillary Donald Trump my problem is
that I don't want to be in this position
in four years and in eight years and in
12 years and in 16 years we're like well
gee man you know like right a guy like
Donald Trump
we never thought he'd be a reality TV
star and come out and be a presidential
candidate who knew right I I'd kind of
like to have good people out there
people like you said that can see an
election cycle change and what people
need to say it changed Donald Trump
changed that game and maybe that's a
good legacy for him maybe he's gonna
make politicians be a little bit more
honest and a little bit more forward
instead of all these can practice lines
that they just keep throwing out at
speech after speech maybe that's a good
thing we've done I've said before the
campaign's will never be the same they
shouldn't be the cycle they'd never be
the same a long time ago just as fresh
listen I am this is not a policy but I
am just as frustrated with the GOP as
Trump people are because they are so
mind-numbingly stupid tonight I mean
first off I don't even understand how
does Lindsey Graham how does Mitch
McConnell get to beam up
addition of power how does the GOP go
this is a sound yeah we're good with it
they're absolute morons morons and Ted
Cruz is brilliant when it comes to the
Constitution when it comes to running a
campaign fast enough at all he deserved
to lose they deserve does it mean that
Donald Trump deserved to win
no it's like watching one of those awful
smoker fights where they're just they're
just clinging on to each other for dear
life and one of them gets hauled on a
stretcher and the other guy only won
because one of them went into cardiac
arrest because they couldn't get on a
treadmill that was this election no one
were and I know everyone it's popular to
always [ __ ] no one did a good job drunk
did a good job with the campaigning but
I mean I we have to be fair there I know
Gerald is too but it's just you think a
job with very little understanding of
how the campaign process works
he understood people and that's what you
need to understand and unfortunately a
presidential race and and most of
politics has turned into a popularity
contest what happens in high school when
you'd vote for class president in the
most popular person wins they do nothing
same thing happens it carries over or
they promised you freedom people but you
know what you're doing you're doing what
I get upset with with conservatives and
a host doing that's true so adapt yeah
and well that survives is not the
strongest it's not the fastest it's the
animal that adapts so yeah you're right
that's true but that's reality and the
GOP has been just been saying that and
bitching about it but you know what
Carly Fiorina Ted Cruz not only should
have been back on this program like I
said Adam Carolla shows like Joe Rogan
Howard Stern all these shows that
conservatives don't like because of
naughty language they should have been
doing that and then I didn't and that
really you know and I'm just taught
using those as an example but the same
thing the way they would use social
media the way they would try and you
know go into the only the Christian
white Bible Belt type voter districts
it's just it's it's asinine and and I'm
just as mad with them we need it a
little more drunk Ted Cruz at night
tweeting from for himself yes we did
that's what the world needed fed with a
few bottles of scotch handy not a few
bottles Gerald you're trying to kill him
to get a sip occasionally come on you
know you gotta have a stock yeah you
have one glass hanging around he did say
he was a scotch guy which surprised me
because I thought it was a Southern
Baptist picture this thought just
tweeting about this earlier this week
Trump's president
but we film every moment of it like The
Truman Show and eret because no he
doesn't know no he doesn't know we will
see where those tweets can I think that
is illegal
alright Gerald what else did you want to
get off your chest on this Mike my chest
I I really wanted to mention that you
should probably take your shirt off on
air next time if you're gonna change
just for the ladies I might well know
that for it's not gonna be for the
ladies believe me if you look at our if
you look at our followership it's gonna
be much yeah very strong gay libertarian
conservative following so we're pretty
grateful for that I think it's gonna
take places and all six of them find
this market niche markets but the
t-shirts are coming well that's a
perfect example right there are plenty
of gay people out there who are
frustrated with that you know I don't
know why people like Ted Cruz and Carly
Fiorina weren't really focusing on the
winning issues like the freedom of
speech and the social justice left they
don't get it they don't get it that
that's a big issue right now it's a big
winning issue if they focused on and I
never even talked about it
I agree at one other thing I didn't want
to say is don't vote third party make a
choice either choose to vote for the
person that you want to win or choose to
vote against them right if you if you I
mean they're choose to vote against the
other person make the choice don't vote
third-party third-party basically just
splits the vote and whoever if you're a
Republican and you vote third party all
you've done is split the vote it's not
gonna help anything
[Music]
at a certain point a protest vote I'm
not saying necessarily but I liked what
Austin Peterson had to say on the show
at a certain point when you are so not
represented at all I'm not saying people
should vote third party but I think it's
it's defensible a protest vote at that
point well here's here's why I would
disagree with you okay how about you
show me that you wanted a protest before
the vote came maybe go out and do some
not you how about somebody who really
wants to have a protest but I'm gonna
vote for this third party candidate
because I don't like this guy why don't
you get involved earlier on in the
process you're gonna come into the game
late and saying well I just don't like
my options right now I'm gonna I'm gonna
cry better on Twitter I'm go do
something about it then you can protest
vote and I'll be right there with you
saying yeah absolutely
you tried your hardest and nobody up
there is good but I think at a point
though where they're going to be signa
bout this right now the Democrats are
more likely to go they're the ones who
could go to a contested convention
with a socialist yes
democratic socialist away wait what well
you know there's gotta be a lot of them
to just it would love Trump to be
President just so they can't blame all
the Hillary crap on Democrats hold on
real quick
I'm just looking at Twitter someone's
asking if Nick DiPaolo was sleeping I
read his tweets and his voice says I'm
wide awake jerk-off I didn't love Nick
to follow he tweets but yeah The Voice
agree I listen that you're a little
fascist you know I'm going I'm freaking
wide awake oh yeah yes I agree agree
with you jail but some people earn the
right at this point if they felt like
they've been really active and they've
been snubbed this is different it is
very different because of how personal
it has been and I don't think you can
unify after this no I mean it's it's
gonna be really hard to turn out solid
Republican base on this you're not gonna
get a lot of guys who were gonna vote
for anybody else on the on the line to
come out and really be excited about
Trump I don't see it I mean there's
plenty of other people that are excited
about him he could win the rallies I get
it but he could win he could yeah he
could it's unlikely but yeah it's
absolutely possible I reserve the right
to never make a prediction again Stephen
calm down it's gonna be fine a couple of
months from now we're not even gonna be
talking Trump
Stephen don't worry about it he won't
make it to the top nine doled out the
top five funny three crap it's funny
because of all the pro Trump people and
we have my Lonnie saying I don't get it
but when you're on I was saying I think
you're under estimating him anyone who
would come on with a view that even if I
agree they're gonna think that I
disagree with them just because I feel
required to I hear so many softballs all
the time on the radio like people you
give a softball to Carly Fiorina
do you watch the same interview at that
point before the first debate and I said
your tenure at HP was less than
impressive how do you answer your
critics is there any more biting issue
for Carly even even after even after
this this week people are joking on
Twitter about how she joined the
campaign just enough to lay off a bunch
of people that's still the joke that's
still that still the hit at Carly right
you know that's still there yeah
absolutely I mean what senator Ted Cruz
ya know you just come across as out of
touch why don't you why don't you do
this more
it's the packaging wheat for yourself we
said we'd said that on it yourself
you know
yeah I think you're right jail but I
don't know where they government I think
Donald Trump could win just because
here's the thing where you hear a lot of
other I was listening I don't listen to
it often but another conservative radio
host saying well you know here we are
conservative left without an option and
that was the bitching segment and I'm
gonna hold on a second a lot of people
don't care we are at a point where they
just your conservatism they go yeah
because most of the country's in
conservative our job is to convince
people who are now they've taken the red
pill the reason why you have is because
these principles constitutionalism
federalism this is why they're important
as opposed to just one guy
so framing it as though welcome to
conservatives now no no there are people
who are willing to listen Trump as a
step and I think there gonna be some
convincing going on there and that's why
I don't just want to boom hashtag never
Trump and shut the door on some of those
people I agree I understand what you're
saying I just think you're gonna hear
whatever he thinks it's gonna take for
him to get support of course I don't
want to be lied to I mean if he's the
guy he says he is then stay that way
right don't try to come and be this
great unifier like your commercials in
between the segments are talking about
you're not gonna unify us you meant
exactly what you said of course you
meant that otherwise you wouldn't have
said it don't come back and kind of
smooth it over and say oh we're gonna
make America great again together it's
it's all of us together no no that's not
what you ran on so just be honest at
least right now I agree with you it's
gonna be a clear war I want to hear his
answer on the Donna North Carolina trans
issue now because it Trump's Trump's we
know what he did before but now with
this gross violation and a lot of how
all the the media the Trump media out
there just completely Gloucester they
just try to bare yet so fast because
they couldn't switch they knew they
could switched positions cuz they were
all still pumping out like the night
before was curtain room stuff yep and
then the next morning was Trump was
trimming out in support in North
Carolina social justice warrior law okay
before we go Gerald what do you think
about that about the
the court saying hey hey North Carolina
you can't do that yep till Monday I'd
say come and get me there are plenty of
trainees who are willing to oblige yeah
I was talking to a guy about he's a
super liberal I was talking to a buddy
of mine seconds go and he said I was
like is there this problem that I wasn't
aware of where all these people were
being denied bathroom access if a girl
walks into a guy's bathroom that looks
like a guy nobody's gonna ask anything
what was going on that was so bad I'm
going to have some questions but we have
to go to the break Gerald Morgan jr.
thanks for being with us stay tuned last
segment
[Music]
oh my god it's happening the new mineral
makeup yeah I know it's expensive but
you know sometimes you have to just
splurge it's better in my school no I
hope it is that it sounds like someone
being standing up I think so hello
ladies um I think you're in the right
place
no no yeah it's totally cool the judge
said so you know civil rights and what
have you um I think it works like let me
stop you right there I can tell you that
it works exactly that way don't think
that well you know I got the ACLU right
here in my favorites I could just call
them up and I'm sure I'm right no no
that's fine that's fine don't wanna my
gosh will lose your good good good oh
yeah we're fine um Larry Larry right you
know I'm really glad to hear that
because I'm about to go back in there
and drop the Huxtables off at the pool
um is that is that racist oh might be if
I weren't a [ __ ] but that's a fight
you want to pick no no no no that's
what's up ladies I have got to go fair
warning to anyone of you who takes a
stole next to me I take a particularly
wide stance okay have a good one was
that I was thinking was that Larry Craig
[Music]
whoa
Jared what are you doing shoot began
with what's your 50 where'd you get it
ar-15 eka oh there's another one oh you
got him yeah for ar-15 dot-com they have
ar-15 and accessories for sale and the
best advice there is on the web oh no
there's another one you gotta with your
what ar-15 from where ha that's the best
place to go and that's a take away
because it's Gordon lit up a stop
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back final segment you're
watching the video really call it this
is called the leo labs of the dead it's
called the Leonardo DiCaprio for those
who didn't we didn't listen to the
podcast and no one did
a long time ago when we did that whole
Titanic theme podcast oh yeah it's but
we talked I was always amazing Titanic
when she just you know this is great as
a love story ever told
and she was annoyed by his frozen corpse
and a life raft and just I mean I can't
imagine doing that to my wife
I can imagine do it to you I don't want
c-diff on my life but I just never think
of that like there are so many things
wrong with that movie or or the notebook
it's pornography for women that's what
you know there was a movie done the one
with Joseph gordon-levitt and Scarlett
Johansson Scarlett Johansson
she was / lord Vader yes if she walked
into your bathroom you just heard her
voice in the stall next you'd be calling
your senator oh yeah oh yeah Oh Mike
Huckabee come save me the Thai food
oh hey Hansen know who did you figure it
was Shia LaBeouf no no by the way
another storm we were talking about it
parents supporting this the six-year-old
was going into class as a transgender
and you know I saw the story and it just
sort of came out at me the idea of and I
hate to do the whole common sense thing
but when since when do we allow children
small children to make permanent
decisions regarding their sexuality
orientation or gender fluidity
I would love them to pick their career
too though like what 17 yeah but here
decided gender at six most of them can't
do that right no in here Albany thing
was a hate crime hate the hate crime
Albany story was a hoax we have that up
on the website you have to go check that
out they've been indicted so much stuff
just happened
we just didn't have Emma NIST's were
furious about attractive cheerleaders I
don't know if you saw this this was
another story they were mad that
cheerleaders are attractive they
apparently want cheerleaders to look
like trig Lee puffs there was a black
racist in South Africa who bragged about
making a white r8r waitress cry I'm just
kind of I don't want to do this we're
saying there are so many stories we
wanted to get to we need to do another
we needed to get this show going more
than once a week at this point I'm going
to do a video on Karl Marx oh I want to
sort of talk about this here before we
before we release the video something
that is this is mainstream it's what
your little brother was the one who sent
me this video yeah but this because it's
being shown in all my class classes and
he's like 14 yeah he's 14 he's hilarious
by the way one of the biggest smart
alecks there is and it says Karl Marx
video it has over a million plays and
people are pret and the guy is clearly
in the pocket for Karl Marx and at one
point he talks about how Karl Marx
believes that that profit for
corporations was theft theft from the
worker and it's funny when you think
about that we are at a point where
that's no different what Bernie people
believe okay I'm not saying they're
communists but it's no different they
believe that it's theft for corporations
to have on I guess sort of unfair profit
margins so we think it's theft for
corporations or a business order to make
a profit but not actual theft because
what does the government do yeah they
step in they say we're taking your money
to the profit no here men with guns
we're taking your money that's actual
theft so a business owner who's created
I don't know the Big Mac and as now the
family is now a billionaire or Walmart
wear your deodorant prices went down 72%
and you shop there that's theft taking
their stuff isn't theft that's where we
are that's what a lot of people believe
at this point they believe this is
what's so hard with a generation with
this election - you have a lot of people
obviously in the Trump side still just
just purely voting in their own
self-interest saying well is not about
principles now I'm just gonna vote in my
own self-interest and that's okay
protectionism it can only take that so
far before it changes before the kids
you have and the demographics change a
little bit and the next person votes in
their own self-interest and then they
mob you that
that's that's the order of these things
that's where they go a good example
things that left us really hate right
they really hate we were talking on this
earlier earlier socialism left us hate
big corporations big banks right big but
we hate big banks well listen so do I I
hate big banks but let's walk this down
the logic trail the only reason that
those big banks can continue to be big
banks or monopolies is because of the
people you really hate right the corrupt
politicians Karl Marx acknowledge
there's corruption in any kind of a
hierarchy so big banks continue to be
big banks because of a never knowing
supply of bailout funds from big
government big politicians whom you hate
right so what happens under communism or
socialism that big government bailing
out the big bank who you hate who you
don't trust they now are the bank and
they're your only bank it's one of those
great ironies that is lost and I think
it's lost on a lot of people when it
comes to the Trump side certainly to the
Bernie side I think that's what that's
why there's a lot of crossover we've
looked at our analytics it is a stunning
number at how many people who are either
Trump or Bernie at first glance you go
that's silly there's no way no there is
a way we can see people coming in to of
course we have all the comments and
people going I just want someone who's
independent Bernie or Trump people go in
from Ron Paul to Bernie
at a certain point I understand listen a
lot of people aren't on board with
principled conservatism I get it and
that's why we don't assume that you are
but at a certain point for you
regardless of how I'm presenting it
principles have to come into play
someone at some point every system of
government can't be subjective to the
populous as any whim at some point you
have to decide either an appropriate
role of government or what it is that
you believe if you're angry with banks
why if you're angry with the GOP why if
you're angry at Mitch McConnell why if
you don't want to vote Donald Trump why
third party why we try to answer those
questions and sometimes I'm not as clear
as I I wish I could be I hope we were on
the situation with Trump tonight I
certainly hope that we were on the Bruce
Jenner Caitlyn Jenner getting medals on
Sports Illustrated tucking tucking front
tail at level Oh bill
but if you are going to get mad or vote
you need to ask yourself and you need to
be able to answer publicly why anger in
itself is not enough just like I was
talking about being offensive in and of
itself is not enough there's nothing
wrong with being angry there's nothing
wrong with being offensive if it is a
means to an end if there is a goal
simply being angry or offensive for its
sake you're not accomplishing anything
we'll talk to you next week think about
it or don't ladder with Crowder
[Music]